you've described that there are people
in your life I'm talking about big stars
like Taylor Swift who you'll call from
time to time or hang out with how many
people can you talk about the pressures
in your life the pressures of writing
songs coming up with this kind of art
that people respond to I feel very
fortunate in that respect because you
know there's very few people that are
going to understand
where you're at um almost no one yeah I
mean there's one guy in in England
called uh Robbie Williams who's like
huge outside of America that had a very
similar career to trajectory to me right
I speak to him a lot as well him Taylor
I mean Harry as well is in the same sort
of uh thing and solo artists but do you
ever feel that like you're bothering
them I think it depends on the day
sometimes I'll just drop an email like
with with Robbie I watched the
documentary of his and it really made me
feel less alone and I emailed him being
like I just watched the documentary and
I just related to so much of it and it
made me feel less alone and then he
emailed me straight back being like
ironically that has made me feel less
and I think it's good just to be open
and talk Chris Martin does this amazing
thing that I I don't know if he knows
that he's doing it but but whenever he
likes one of my songs he sends me an
email being like I really like this song
man and and it's just that he probably
just goes I like this song I'm emailing
him but I grew up listen to him and he's
one of my musical Heroes and I I love
him I've based my sort of career
trajectory and album things on what he's
sort of done with Coldplay albums and I
just really love and respect him and he
doesn't know when he's emailing me I'm
like oh man that's just made my day and
uh yeah I try to do that whenever like
Elton sort of taught me this thing uh
inadvertently that you know Elton is
constantly seeking out new talent and
and being a mentor for them and being
and I feel like I don't want to speak to
for him but I feel like that has
probably been away over the years to
always root for the next person and not
ever feel like anyone's taking your spot
early on in my career I had my first
um spurt and everyone was like Ed's the
new guy let's all go for it and then
there was someone else that came along
and then they became the new guy and I
found myself being like right I can
either be bitter about this or I can
make friends with them and be supportive
and then I will always love that they're
having success and I sort of feel like
we're all running in a race and uh we'll
all get to the finish line but you don't
want to be tripping anyone up on the way
you want to be like sparing people on
That's So healthy but it's hard to do in
your business because it is like when
Harry Styles comes out and all of a
sudden he's on a roll but I've known
Harry for like I I worked with Harry on
the first One Direction record we used
to live at uh this guy Chris Leonard um
had a a flat and Fulham and I remember
before I had money from my album my
album went number one and Harry had gone
number one with What Makes You Beautiful
that day same day and we were both
staying at Chris's house I've always
rooted for him and I always like like
think that I just think it's amazing
going from the biggest boy band in the
world and then going rebuilding it
coming back with three amazing albums
winning album the year Grammy and then
going back into stadiums it's just it's
a really really impressive Journey
foreign